الثمن والعشرين من مايو ولاول مره في
تاريخ تركيا الحديث
الاتراكز ينتخبون رئيسهم عبر دور ثان جوله
ثانيه وذلك بعد ان فشل كل من رجب طيب
اردوغان وكمال اوغلو في حصد نصف اصوات
الناخبين لتتحول الانبار الى الخاسر في
الجوله الاولى الحصان الاسود السنان اوغان
الذي يمثل خمسه في المئه من الاصوات لديه
وما يكفي لقلبي تاخرك لجدار الى فوز او
حسم النتيجه لصالح اردوغان لكن دعونا اولا
نذكر بما حدث في الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات حصل اردوغان على نسبه
49.52% نال الاغلبيه في 51 ولايه من اصل
81 وفاز في 8 من اصل احدى عشره ولايه
ضربها الزلزال وهي كهرمان مرعش غازي عنتاب
كلس اديمان عثمانيه
بالطبع خسر اردوغان في ديار بكر معقل
الاكراد الى جانب اضنه وهاتاي منافسه كمال
اكل الجدار اوغلو حصل على نسبه اجماليه
بلغت
44.8 من الاصوات هذا اصوات الاغلبيه في 30
ولايه اخرى وابرزها كانت العاصمه انقره
واسطنبول والمفارقه في اتجاهات التصويت في
هاتين المنطقتين انها على الرغم من عدم
تصويتها لاردوغان في انتخابات الرئاسه
صوتت لصالح تحالفه في البرلمان
[موسيقى]
الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات